quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui à 58 ans 31 en
service avec les trois mesures de
récupération de monsieur coiteux elle va
perdre 9000 $ par année
vérification faite c'est vrai la fiq
applique à la lettre les propositions
gouvernementales
un scénario fictif d'une infirmière de
58 ans qui gagne en moyenne 70 mille
dollars par année
d'abord la rente annuelle d'une
infirmière dans cette situation serait
calculée sur ces huit meilleures années
au lieu de cinq
selon la fiq cela ne présenterai dans un
premier temps une baisse de 812 $ par
année
ensuite en repoussant l'âge de la
retraite de 60 à 62 ans et en faisant
passer de 4% à 7 2% la pénalité pour
chaque année de retraite anticipée la
rente pour cette infirmière qui est
présentement de 38 mille dollars par
année passerait à 29 mille dollars donc
une perte de 9000 $ au conseil du trésor
on ne rejette pas les calculs de la fiq
par contre on rappelle qu'avant 1996 la
pénalité pour une retraite anticipée
était de 6 % par année
le gouvernement de lucien bouchard
l'avait alors réduite à quatre pour ça
pour encourager les départs à la
retraite il si denis martin chabot radio
canada montréal c'est pas acceptable
qu'au xxième siècle en france on puisse
surveiller des personnes pour une
activité syndicale ou politique
ça se passe en france mais le débat
rappelle celui qui entoure le projet de
loi c 51 ici même au pays